a new study of 2000 Millennials finds
that a third believe their lives are
more stressful than the average person's
and 60% feel that life is more stressful
than ever before okay to hold those
opinions you cannot have been alive or
cognizant during world wars terror
attacks crime waves killer diseases when
Jimmy Carter was president the cuban
missile crisis or when dinosaurs walked
the earth how else can you believe that
living in the most prosperous peaceful
time in existence the Trumpy era is
stressful you want stressful look up
1942 or Don Knotts but I think your life
is worth stressful thinking your life is
more stressful is simply human nature we
all find our own hangnail more urgent
than a distant outbreak of malaria but
there are worse stressors here are three
this guy might be President this could
be your boss this could be you and thank
God you don't wake up to this every
morning or looking like this or laughing
like this yeah now top daily stresses
included a damaged phone screen and
ignored social media posts so life is
good that's not a gas crisis or
stagflation no one remembers that I'm
old but also the real stressors never
change
losing a wallet came in first second was
an argument with your partner so even in
this new world no matter how great your
day is it all goes to hell when you know
who isn't speaking to you so we have
some in common with our parents their
parents and their parents a cold
shoulder still hurts more so than zero
likes and hooray for that that made me
happy Dana that people still get upset
about human interaction yeah that
happened to Peter and made a couple
weeks ago yeah he woke up on the wrong
side of the bed I hate that bad mood and
he yelled at Jasper
he said he's made it he's going to get
out of the way like in the in the bed
and I was like how can you do that
then he said basically I'm sorry feeder
I'm telling you the story but then I
said and then he started mocking me I
was like uh and I didn't speak to him
for four hours Wow
I thought the Conway is that a problem
no the equivalent of the Conway's would
be Peter going to some other Network
trashing Jasper Peters on Animal Planet
yeah we made up though Emily I guess
technically you're a millennial no I'm
not I went to gender I was born in the
70s oh well I'm not you're 50 you're
gonna be 50 this March close to it yeah
okay here's my issue I feel like of
course the number one thing they're
afraid of is disconnection because they
don't have real connections on the
outside yeah and also I went to this
party and there are a bunch of
influencers there and I was like oh
interesting whatever and they were all
children none of them knew how to speak
none of them knew how to have a
conversation I was horrified I left
early with verbal and also I had a good
idea for reality show I think we should
have to be Millennials versus everyone
else and then you have to like navigate
a city or navigate life and they can't
use their devices they have to enter you
know they have to like ask for
directions like scuse me sir or be like
excuse me can you take a picture of me
like and see how they succeed which they
won't they'll obviously shrivel and
[Laughter]
while you you're you are divorced from
technology so that's not divorce I had
two cellphones and I you know live on an
iPad when I'm I even read books now
first took me a long time to get
yesterday because I like hard covers but
anyway what's your daily stressor then
that's no but I can name it but no but I
think that when young people talk about
this I think it ties into loneliness I
think it ties into a sense being
separate you know jealous of other
people yeah because other people have
things are on some great trip and the
like right Instagram yeah so the
alienation to me is a big factor and I
see it by the way in suicide numbers
among young people that it's an
offensive
because they were being bullied and
guess what it's coming through that kind
of media but to me there we're living
through changing times yeah and they're
there the tip of the spear in terms of
having been influenced and growing up
with this everything from pornography to
music is different for these yeah and
it's and we've said this before
technology is way ahead of humanity
we're catching up Jesse one of the
stressors was engine light goes on in
car I was so happy that they did what a
car was or an engine light that is
stressful it happened to me the other
day was not a pretty picture Greg a
hundred years ago they didn't have a
word for stress it was just called life
we woke up you went to work I went to
war you came home you had a drink and
you went to bed
that was it I mean last century there
was a draft people had their heads
cracked open protesting civil rights
they literally had kids dying because
they didn't have the right medicine and
now kids are upset because they're got
not getting likes I was reading the New
York Times magazine the other day and
there's a great quote I'd like to share
because I blame the parents for these
Millennials it says parents should
prepare their kid for the road not the
road for the kid and these kids so
they're never uncomfortable and whenever
they face adversity they melt down
that's why my parents sent me to these
outdoor wilderness survival school to
make me so uncomfortable try to kill you
you suffer like I love this story like
when with the when you got blisters on
your feet and then my face Dana I had
think oxide all over my face because my
face peeled off we all take pleasure in
your suffering yes I should come over to
for Thanksgiving